review of set
theory
Set builder notation not set theory.
in the mathematics
sets are represented with
curly brackets
now we have
Specific types of sets but I'll come down in a moment.
So for example, this is a set.
One two three, right? We have a set with three elements.
One, two, three, we use those words.
And we can use a letter to represent it. So we have to set a
with elements 1 2 3
now
a vector
maybe not jump ahead too quickly. Let's let me call this a vector
space because we're going to come this in a moment.
And also if so, this is
a set we call its these numbers in here. Yeah, it's
elements and if we want to use such
polar notation.
Let me actually show your set builder notation. Say we have
the set.
Let's do a again.
This time using set builder we can say x such
that.
X is an integer
X such that X
Is an integer.
and
X is between
1 and 3
so
X
l e q
3 so what we're doing what this?
Expression is saying is producer set with elements X.
So we're going to have these x's in this set.
Such that the X's are integers.
I'll tell you what this Z is in a second if it's not clear if
you haven't seen this before.
And X is between 1 and 3.
So, of course we have the number system. Let me take let me go
up one level.
And this is we will come to this in a moment. We will
return to this topic once we get the abstract algebra the number
systems.
So we have the natural numbers, for example.
Which are indicated with the letter n?
You can see that there is this.
a two lines
so it's not just a normal letter the capital letter and it's it
looks like that.
And this is the this is the set of numbers.
from
zero
one two
until then
but these are all of course.
their whole numbers
so no.
The whole there's no fraction. And of
course, they are not signed so.
No positive or negative.
This is the natural numbers.
I won't do all of them just a few of them. So you get the idea and then
we have the integers.
Which is like the natural numbers, but they also go on the negative side.
So we have negative one.
negative 2 Etc
Okay.
Should have put here Infinity.
Maybe
minus
Okay.
And then we have the real numbers. This one
will be definitely want to know because
the real numbers are always.
denoted in linear algebra, and that is just the
set of
rational and irrational numbers
so the numbers like pi and E.
Oil is number. These are irrational numbers.
Because they are not repeating and then we have the rational numbers.
Okay, so we won't get to the complex number system or this
is sufficient. So if you see
letters that look like this they have
this line Crossing through the letter.
Then we talk about a number system.
So down here, what are we saying?
we are saying that a
Again, as a set containing elements X
such that this vertical bar is pronounced.
Or it's red as such that alternatively we
can use a colon in here like so.
So these are interchangeable.
So X such that X is an integer.
And it is between one and three including one and
three.